you don't fire a guy like me like that
he put the creature of the Black Lagoon
okay in charge of the swamp as the White
House chief of staff I mean this guy
Reince Priebus is like a walking
disaster okay he is the elemental avatar
of everything that America dislikes
about Washington and so he makes him the
chief of staff never understood that
and what do you achieve Stan yeah I
don't know how much it would go back and
forth and he says I got a call from
trumpet said he's not gonna be the
candidate we're going a different
direction I'm talking 15 16 like early
stages so octo after the axis hollywood
davie Tolman's drop out he hated the
president so why would he hire him
though ah well I think what ended up
happening was the president made
correctly an assessment that there was a
positive attribution to the Republican
Party ground game that helped him attain
the president's gotta and he was trying
to reward Priebus and he thought he was
a good administrator but you can't hire
the creature of the Black Lagoon to
drain the swamp when every impulse every
grain of DNA and the person's body is to
add more water add more swamp water to
the swamp I think of a previous tip
Priebus basically blocked every single
person from New York that was on the
president's team and he couldn't block
Jared or vodka but every other person
got blocked
give me a shield shield it prevented
every person from getting jobs in the
administration oh I see what I was
supposed to do PL director he blocked me
told stories about me told lies about me
he ran opposition research about me he
told John cats and matías a well-known
entrepreneur here that really bad
nefarious stuff is gonna come out on
Anthony so he figured I was Italian and
I worked on Wall Street for 30 years so
I must have done something wrong and so
he had opposition research people
digging into my past he couldn't find
anything okay so he was a very very
dishonest very innocent he's one of the
worst people that I've met in my life so
far actually yeah one of the worst
people ruthless dishonest
without conscience and unbelievably
diabolical and it wasn't really that
smart interesting so what would really
not that smart people do Patrick is they
make up for it with their ruthlessness
and their guile they'll do things that
you and I wouldn't
you're an entrepreneur so definitiely
and if your business is successful you
have to run it off of a platform of
ethics you can't really run it as an
unethical enterprise it'll eventually
get caught I'll eventually get caught
and so it catches up with you so you
have to run it off a platform of ethics
and honor and which is what I do at
skybridge so I didn't anticipate the
nonsense that Washington would do to
each other so I'm not in my DNA I don't
think you would say that about John
Kelly as a human being you just disagree
with his decisions he made right you
wouldn't put him at the site say
something differently which I know he
was a more honorable guy he served the
country John Kelly is a gold star family
memories lost his son on war he's a
decorated four-star general in the
United States Marine Corps so there was
an honor to that but I would say that
John Kelly was a round peg in a square
hole you know he had the wrong
personality for the president in the
wrong temperament you can't think of
yourself as being better or having a
better reputation and the person you're
working for that's never gonna work
the other thing John Kelly did which I
totally disagree with he was too
militant in the job see his firing of me
not to make this about me but I'm just
giving you a case study example in
management the way he fired me in the
abrupt the way that he fired me actually
was the match that he struck for his own
demise because he set the culture up in
a way that was militant and intimidating
and it caused people to create more
insecurity and more backbiting and more
paranoia he could have said to me hey
ant you did a disastrous thing on the
phone and that's absolutely fireable
offense I don't want you working here in
the White House but you served the
president and you've been part of his
media advocacy you worked on his
transition team and you seemed like a
good enough guy wants to take two weeks
off okay and when you return on Labor
Day we'll come up with a story that
you're leaving and so this way you don't
explode out of here okay that's what we
would have done on Wall Street right but
he wanted to hit me as hard as he could
hit me okay and as I tried to point out
to him you don't fire a guy like me like
that because when you fire a guy like me
like that you're sending an earthquake
and a shock wave
into the system oh my god if they could
fire a guy like him like that what do
they do to me right and when I told the
president is what John did to you
was unfortunate because he did something
to you that made you look very bad and
it made him look very good and his job
is to make you look good he's her chief
of staff but it made him look good like
he's John tough guy
in the John Wayne movie as a US Marine
and you allowed him to do it to one of
your buddies that helped you get elected
okay so I made you look bad and made him
look good and it caused the match to get
struck to lead to his demise so my issue
with Kelley is more of a managerial
issue and the way you interact with
people but no he's not a nefarious
you've always wanted good things
about an individual it's not a member of
the Leviathan like rancid penis or this
guy Adolph Bannen I mean these guys are
like caulk I don't wanna yeah I mean
this guy's a horrific guy so you know
why I believe in God tell me because
well you know if you ever have I believe
in guys I raised my parents I believe in
God but like we have doubts in your
faith you know what I can think of I can
reflect upon Steve Banta is a very smart
very articulate guy very well-read guy
very seductive guy but God made him so
ugly Patrick he is so ugly that he saved
the civilization from Steve Bennett you
know with that nose and that face and he
dresses a contemporary hobo don't be
gonna take him seriously thank God
okay so so this guy's a human disaster
okay I would debate this guy anywhere on
the civilization I debate him on a live
stage on a youtube channel I would
debate him in a public square because
he's got a lot of facts but a lot of
those facts are twisted in his brain and
he has a very evil egocentric nefarious
agenda and he could put a real hurt on
the civilization if he was in Balrog I
like him thank God he looks like that
who is president Trump trust today who
does he trust today he's obviously trust
minuchin Steven minuchin Mike Pompeo
he's got a very good relationship with
Jared obviously he trusts his daughter
Ivanka there's other people in the
administration bill Cheyenne River I was
recruiting bill shine right here because
you know entrepreneurs I I don't want to
be the smartest guy in the room I
I hire 10 guys that are 10 times smarter
than me ok so when he gave me the coms
job I'm like I'm the best guy for that
let me go hire the best guys I'm gonna
go hire bill shine its president Fox
News he would be able to figure out how
to do this way better than me
so I'm very happy that Bill's there you
know a people hire A+ people and by the
way if you're listening to this and
you're not an a person put some delusion
and you'll I started thinking of
yourself like an a person because if you
think yourself like an a person you will
become an a person and a person's hire a
plus people D people hire F people see
people hire D and F people B people hire
C D and F people right you know a proven
is like a C+ person you know he was
maniacally insecure maniacally paranoid
and so you can take this equation that I
have in my brain it's a quadratic
equation on human emotion insecurities
under confidence always equals paranoia
and backstabbing you got eighty at nine
hundred people working for you the ones
that are complaining the ones that are
backstabbing the other people they're
insecure they're under confident I don't
then say anything bad about anybody I'm
I can stand on my own two feet is no
problem you're gonna hit me you're gonna
try to take me down then I got to go
after you
[Music]